[Music]
hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie guide here I'm up to my third
round of Oscar nominations and I'm up to
Best Actor and Best Actress
so the nominees for Best Lead Actor are
Timothy Salome Daniel day-lewis Daniel
Kaluga Gary Oldman Denzel Washington now
looking at each of these a little bit
closer timothy sha'lame is now the third
youngest Best Actor nominee ever the top
two at Jackie Cooper for Skippy in 1931
aged just nine and Mickey Rooney in
babes in arms from 1939 age 19 Timothy
is just 22 years old and he plays Elio
in call me by your name which is a
heartbreaking and beautiful love story
opposite Armie Hammer should have said
anything
just pretend you never did and this is
the first time since 1989 that we have
two best lead actors who are in their
20s the other is Daniel Kalu you forget
out he is wonderful as Chris in Jordan
peels multi-layered horror film that
says so much about racism it's really
scary too and it's all grounded by
Daniels performance just tell me where
people are getting hurt
Yallah Daniel in this categories of
course Daniel day-lewis
he already has the most Best Actor
Oscars in history with three and if he
wins in this category he will tie with
Katharine Hepburn for the most wins
across all four acting categories here
he's nominated for phantom thread where
he plays Reynold Woodcock which is the
name that he came up with himself a
fashion designer in 1950s London and
apparently this is his last movie -
Daniel day-lewis has said he's gonna
retire after this movie and really hope
that's not the case an ambush stop are
you sent here to ruin my evening he's
possibly my entire life
stop
[Music]
gary oldman this is surprisingly only
his second Oscar nomination in an
incredible filmography here he's up for
darkest hour where he plays Winston
Churchill this is an impressive
performance much more than just makeup
gimmick it's a complete transformation
you cannot reason with a tiger when your
heavy sentence and Denzel Washington has
his eighth Oscar nomination for Roman J
Israel Esquire he has expanded on his
own record as the most nominated black
actor in history he plays the title
character in this film who is an aging
lawyer trying to figure out his place in
modern-day society and with all the
activism that's going on right now I'm
sorry I had assisters standing in a
brother city as gendered and sexist and
polite and patronizing and polite so my
prediction cuz we got some of the best
actors in history in this category plus
some very promising new stars but it's
got a big Gary Oldman for darkest hour
put your money on this one this is a
safe bet it's a front-runner I'll be so
surprised if he doesn't win not only for
this brilliant performance but it's
gonna kind of also be for his career too
now let's look at Best Lead Actress the
nominees are Sally Hawkins Frances
McDormand Margot Robbie
Saoirse Ronan and Meryl Streep and this
is pretty rare because we have four out
of the five best lead actress nominees
who are in Best Picture nominees so
everyone except for Margot Robbie and I
Tania because that movie didn't get a
Best Picture nomination so you know make
of that what you will that it that is
extremely extremely rare when it comes
to Best Lead Actress but let's take a
look at these nominees closer
we've got sally hawkins this is her
second Oscar nomination and it's got to
be almost some kind of record that she's
nominated for a role where she pretty
much says nothing at all she plays a
mute Jennifer in the shape of water who
falls in love with a fish man
a union Frances McDormand you can see
her in three billboards outside ebbing
Missouri right now on Fandango now this
is her fifth Oscar nomination and it
could be her second win she plays the
lead character in three billboards a
mother who is trying to deal with the
murder of her daughter and her
frustration at the police who she thinks
and not doing enough you didn't happen
to drill a little hole in the dentist
today did you ah
of course now we have Margot Robbie my
go from Australia with her first Oscar
nomination playing Tonya Harding in a
film that she also produced i Tanya this
is a dark and very funny look at Tanya's
life and that incident with Nancy
Kerrigan come on a friggin person bashes
in their friend's knee who would do that
to a friend
Saoirse Ronan is nominated for Lady Bird
and you can see Lady Bird right now on
Fandango now it is a wonderful film and
it just 23 years old
Saoirse is the second youngest
three-time Oscar nominee just beaten by
Jennifer Lawrence who is also 23 years
old but just by a couple of months so
she gives a very funny and relatable
performance here as Christine aka Lady
Bird what I'd really like is to be on
NASA land bad but math isn't something
you're terribly strong in that we know
of yet and then we have Meryl Streep
this is her 21st Oscar nomination she
has beaten her own record to be the most
nominated actor in Oscar history here
she is nominated for the post where she
plays Katherine Graham who was the
publisher of The Washington Post at the
time when the Pentagon Papers were
published
she had a big decision about whether to
run with it and risk getting in trouble
from the White House or should stay
silent do you have the papers yet those
ladies are incredible but when it comes
to my prediction I am saying Frances
McDormand in three billboards outside a
being Missouri there could be an upset
with someone like Saoirse Ronan
squeezing in at the last second but I
think that Frances has been winning
awards up to this stage and she does a
great job in that movie those are my
predictions but I want to know about you
let me know in the comments below or on
Twitter adulation Malone who do you
think will win Best Lead Actor and Best
Lead Actress and I'll see you next week
with more Oscar predictions
[Music]